so in this note I'd like to introduce
our second speaker MAA snaf who will
talk about um stratify stratify data
look yes thank you very much and also
thanks for the opportunity to be a part
of this Workshop so I'm Matias I'm a PhD
student in ER group in in aren and I'm
close to finishing my PhD and during my
PhD wellish has already told you a lot
of what I have been working on so saming
Providence for Logics and games in
general and today I want to talk about
one of my fav results of this time which
is more of an algorithmic
result um and to better fit this
Workshop I want to well phrase this a
bit in terms of stratify data log so the
title is quite long so let's break it
down a bit uh well we have already seen
what sem ring Provence is and I will
start by very briefly introducing how we
can Define such a semi ring semantics or
semi ring provenance also for stratifi
data lock um and mostly in this part I
want to try to convince you that we need
somehow need greatest fix points when
doing this and then the algorithmic
aspect is of course how can we compute
these fix points and how can we do so
efficiently and this will be the main
result of of this talk and then once we
have this as a nice application of this
we can also Define circuit
representations to efficiently store uh
this Provence for stratify data lock so
I will be a bit quick in the first part
so if you're not familiar with data lock
might be bit difficult to follow but
don't worry because the main result uh
does not depend on data loog so you will
still be able to follow
this so let's start why do we need
greatest fix points to Define this
semantics for stratify data lock let's
first look at data lock because this was
basically where this entire framework of
sem semantics was initiated in 2007 in
this sem paper by Green C in tan and
data lock uh is a rule based query
language like this for example example
you read the rotes from right to left so
in this case if you have an edge then
this means that this tole X Y should
also be in the relation T that we are
defining in this case it's the standard
example of defining a transitive closure
so the second rule means that if you
have an edge from X to Z and we can
already go from Z to Y then we can also
go from X to
Y and we evaluate such a program on the
database in this case we can um present
this database as a graph like this and
to define the semantics I want to take a
slightly unusual way of defining it by
means of equation systems uh they look
like this so basically for every
candidate tle that we have like for
example UW we write down an equation
when this tle will be in the relation T
so either we use the first rule then we
need to direct EDD or we use the second
rule then we have two options in this
graph either using HD or h a and then
relying on another tle of the relation
and to switch to sem semantics now is
very easy we just replace the operations
by semi ring operations and we are done
basically the semantics of this is that
we compute the least solution to the
system and doing so in different semi
Rings gives different results for
example in polinomial semi Rings we get
basically all ways to go from U to W in
power series we get all of the paths to
go there in absorptive semi Rings we
only get the shortest ones where we do
not do any Loops for example here the
sem of positive boan form we could also
do a bit different things we can use
instead of abstract tokens we can
annotate the edges by cost values and
then the same equation system gives us
the minimal cost of of a path from U to
W the only requirement is that all these
sems are Omega continuous which
basically just make sure that these uh
these Solutions always exist now let's
move from this to stratify data Lo the
idea is that we want to add negation to
our language but we oh there's a
question already slide you define
perence by saying it's the solution of
the equation system to the def of Prov
as considering all deration trees is
this the same thing is it OB the same um
I'm not sure how obvious it is but it is
the same thing
yes yeah so you tell Le look Le ref to
what order that's a good question we
also use the natural order here of the
sem so the one uh induced by
addition okay so for data lock we now
want to include or add negation to the
language we cannot do so in any way
because if we Define a relation by its
own negation this does not lead to a
well defined semantics or at least it's
not clear one has to be careful to
define the semantics uh so in sptify
data loog we arrange the program in
layers or stratums and the idea is that
once the first layer is complete we are
then allowed to negate this predicate
here because any will no longer change
so we can now apply the negation here
now in semantics if you deal with
negation then what what we do is we
annotate every Edge in our graph both by
a positive annotation and by a negative
annotation whenever we use the absence
of this Edge and uh well how can we now
Define the semantics well in some semi
Rings it's easy we can just directly
Define the negation operation for
example in po we can just well take the
positive buan formula and negate it and
also for these values here we switch to
the negative annotation then that's
fairly easy but it's not so obvious in
in all semi rings for example in pols
where we have expon it's not really
clear what to do with these and also for
a tropical saming what is the negation
of a cost like seven or cost like zero
depends on the application what would
make sense here it's not so easy to
Define this in general but we want the
semantics which works for a wider class
of semi rings and should give the same
result as this one here for pob and the
way I think the easiest way to define
this in general after we did some
thinking about different versions is
Again by something like a negation
normal form so we want to push the
negation in and if we have these
equation systems there's a particularly
easy way to do this we just take the
equation system for for T this one and
now to express the negation of T we just
dualize the system so that's basically
the same as negation normal form in some
sense so here we just replace the
operations and switch between the
positive and the negative annotations
now the thing is because this one here
requires the least solution and we now
dualize the system now here we have to
compute a greatest solution to this
system in order for this to really
capture this idea of the negation normal
form and the semantics defined in this
way has the properties we want it's
applicable to a wide class of semi Rings
absorptive fronts but also nonabsorptive
fronts but we only look at it for
absorptive fronts and it gives the same
result as the uh direct implementation
for the Post s
ring okay so that's one motivation for
greatest Solutions there is another
motivation which was in fact my primary
one because I was looking not at data
lock I was looking at uh fix Point logic
and there you can do something like say
that there is an infinite path from a
node by this formula here we don't want
to read it also because it contains the
typo here um and if you evaluate this on
a graph like like this three nodes graph
again we use the tropical semi ring to
annotate these edges by cost values then
you get again an equation system similar
to the ones before for example for B we
have two options either pay one plus the
cost from a or pay 20 plus the cost from
C and again it's the greatest solution
here that we want to compute because
this will then give us the information
what the cost of the infinite path is
the minimal cost of an infinite
pa okay so in both of these cases you
want to find greater solution of these
equation systems and this is what I want
to talk about now and also I want to
explain why I'm always talking about
greatest fix points although there's
always greatest Solution on this slide
this is simply because if you have an
equation system like this one it's more
convenient to view this as an operator
defined by polinomial on the right hand
side then you want the greatest fix
Point yeah so if you missed out on any
details about data loog now it's the
point to join back in because this is
now a question which is independent of
data log or any Provence analysis we
just want to find the greatest fix point
of such an operator which has polinomial
on the right hand side right this
doesn't look polinomial but it's
polinomial in the tropical
semi what's the na if approach to find
this fixed point you just start from the
greatest value which in the tropical
semi ring you just have to trust me on
this is the zero El M because the
natural order by addition is somewhat
flipped in the semi ring and then you
repeatedly apply the operator until you
convert to a fix point and indeed you
converge to this fix Point here it's the
same from the last slide two things come
to mind first it takes very long so it's
not feasible for computation and
secondly um you see that the pattern
changes after 20 steps why is that
because we have a coefficient 20 in our
system this is also a bit bad because we
want the complexity to not depend on the
coefficients but only depend on the
number of equations that we
have is a question
yeah Z one we are starting from the one
element of the semi ring in general
which in case of the tropical semi ring
somewhat confusingly is the zero element
so but I think it's easier to understand
the tropical semi ring so I will stick
for this talk I will stick to the
tropical semi ring because I think
besides this small confusing part most
of it is easier to understand here
um okay so can we can we achieve this it
turns out we can so this is the main
result if we have an absorbed fully
continuous semi ring I will explain this
but you've also seen it in the last talk
and we have this operator in N equations
use the pooms in the least fix point is
just iterate the operator end times but
this is something which has been known
before and the new result is that for
the greatest fix point we can do it
similarly we iterate n times from the
one element then we have this special
operation here which I will explain then
we iterate another round of n steps
intuitively if you think of an infinite
path an infinite path if it's a lasso
path it has this reability part and this
looping part and this here accounts for
the loop this does the repetition of the
loop and this is the reability part
basically okay so in in our example uh
this means it looks like this so we
first do these n iterations then apply
the special operation and then do
another round of n iterations in this
case we don't need all of these n
iterations but in general you need all
of them in both places so you can still
computers in a
pol of the operator what is
is so so n is uh the number of variables
that we have or or the aity of the T
that we are operating on so is n three
in your example
yes it's number of entries here
and you say it's enough to itate three
times uh six times I mean for for the
least fix point three and for the
greatest three plus the Special
Operation plus another round of three
yes I think we are puzzled by the
example so apparently you are telling us
that in this example it suffice as to
iterate three times do that Infinity
mambo jumbo and then itate three times
again and that's it
yeah in this example it would suffice to
do only one iteration here and then
immediately do this uh but in general
you need all of these
iterations okay um so I want to talk a
bit about how one can prove this so that
you get an idea of the rules that we use
for this but first I wanted to talk a
bit about these uh conditions on the
semi Rings now we have already heard
about this in the last talk so I can
keep this short we use the natural order
to answer your question from from the
beginning So Def find by addition and
then we require that we have a supremum
and an infimum of every chain because we
need both basically so this is the
technical condition that we need and you
can mostly forget about it it's not very
important for this talk the important
condition is absorption and this is the
one which we technically do not need so
we could also Define the semantics for
certifi data log without absorption but
as said it turns out that we get
meaningful information if you assume
this also another nice thing is we get
that the semantics works well with
continuous homomorphisms this is
something uh which does not work in
general semi rings but it does work in
these absorptive
cies and well this is absorption for all
elements a we have this equality um it's
actually equivalent to these other two
Notions so the sem is one bounded and
also that multiplication is decreasing
and this is the one I want you to
remember so I've made a picture for this
where multiplication is going down
because that's the one we're going to
need and also this explains that we have
some Duality between addition and
multiplication which is the intuitive
idea why absorption is is helpful here
okay yeah so uh absortion is it
necessary for the result on the last
slide yes for this result it's necessary
sorry but to define the semantics for
for data log for certifi data log it is
not necessary I see and then for least
pit fix point I'm familiar with
requiring plus and times to be monotone
and then here you're requiring it to be
decreasing so would that be create a
problem for this fix no no um they are
both
monotone uh you can you can show this
um um yeah so addition is monotone
because of this I think and
multiplication is monotone uh because of
distributivity because of distributivity
exactly okay so now we have that
multiplication is decreasing so if we
multiply the same element repeatedly we
get a decreasing chain and this
converges the INF of this is then some
value because of our assumption here and
this defines this infinite power
operation just repeatedly multiply the
value and take the INF of
that okay so these are all the
ingredients we need now how can we prove
this result on a very high level it
takes only two ingredients derivation
trees and absorption so let's see how
how these work what are these derivation
trees I think it's a common concept here
we again have an an operator I chose a
more complicated one than before because
the the first one was linear the trees
would be very not very interesting this
one is nonlinear because we have these
two indeterminate here uh these trees
are defined as you would expect
basically like for a formal grammar for
example you start by X and then you have
two ways either use this derivation of
paying five or you pay one plus the cost
of X and Y combined in this case I chose
the letter option pay one so this is
supposed to be a price tag and then here
we have X and Y and continue the tree
from there here I stop paying five and
here I continue and so on this defines a
tree in this case an infinite one and
the cost of this tree is simply the
combined cost in this case it's
infinite there are of course also finite
derivation
trees now I'm not the first one to look
at derivation trees in the context of
fixman computation in fact I was
inspired by this very interesting line
of research on Newton's method in semi
Rings uh some 10 years ago which rier
will give a talk tomorrow so I don't
want to spoil anything here um but the
idea is to take Newton's method to
approximate zeros uh of pooms which uses
derivatives and generalizes to semi
rings to compute fix points and it looks
something like
this I don't want to take credit for the
Photoshop SC I stole this picture from a
presentation um but so in my terminology
what one can say here is that the least
fix Point can be expressed as the
minimal cost of all the finite
derivation
trees in these absorptive semi- rings
and what I'm now saying is that the
greatest fix Point can be expressed if
you also take the infinite trees into
account how to prove this correspondence
between trees and fix points well we
start from the fixman iteration and if
we take the minimum over the cost of all
the trees so we cut the trees off after
the first layer we get the first
iteration step if you cut them off later
we get the subsequent iteration steps um
now the difficult part is to show that
what happens if we apply the infimum so
on the right side it converges to the
greatest fix Point that's easy on the
left side it converges to the minimum
over these entire trees this is easy to
prove for least fixed points difficult
to prove for greatest fixed points
because these trees are now infinite and
so we basically have to show that the
infimum commutes with this minimum or in
general with the supremum this does not
hold in in arbitrary cases it works here
because these trees are defined by
polinomial so they are finally branching
and well behaved in a sense but that's
the first difficult step now remember
what our starting point was we had this
infinite iteration and I said well it's
bad it's infinite it's difficult to
compute now we have achieved this we
have greatly simplified Our Lives we now
have just to compute the cost of
infinitely many infinite trees it's much
simpler than before um but it becomes
simpler once we apply absorption so this
means again multiplication is
decreasing or to put it simpler in the
in the tropical semi ring all we have to
care about is we have to count these
price tags these coefficients if they
occur more often every price tag occurs
more often in One Tree compared to
another tree obviously the first tree is
more expensive and that's all we need to
know because we only want to compute the
minimum of these trees we can then only
look at the second tree so the idea is
instead of looking at a very difficult
tree like this one here obviously very
very irregular and difficult we
transform it to a nicer tree which is
easy to work with and show that this
does not increase the cost how do we do
it well we check which of these tags
occur infinitely often uh let's say
these are the ones and we look where
they first occur in the tree let's say
these are the first
occurrences then we cut the tree off
there and and from there on because they
occur infinitely often also some of the
derivations must occur infinitely often
and so on and we commit to this we
always do the same derivation from these
indeterminist so we get a tree which is
deterministic or periodic in a sense uh
which is already nicer to work with we
still have this prefix here it could be
large uh but everything here appears
only finitely often and well if we have
a repetition then clearly it would be
better to just avoid the repetition and
directly do this part um because then
the cost will only be smaller
and then we obtain nice trees which have
a prefix of at most height n because
after n we must have a repetition Then
followed by these deterministic or
periodic trees they can still be
infinite but they are easy to understand
because they repeat the same pattern
over and over and for the minimum it
suffices to work with these nice trees
how could the minimum
cost sorry how could the minimum cost
infinite
uh how the minimal cost could be
infinite I mean if there if there is no
way to to if there is no finite
tree I see but also you have take into
account that this is a bit of a
simplification here because here
minimum so it's particularly simple in
this semi ring because we have the
minimum operation in the general semi
ring we don't have a linear order so we
don't have a minimum we have a sum so
then every Tre contribute something it's
not just a minimum but even here it it
can happen that we have to look at these
infinite trees actually because the
infinite tree could have finite cost and
it could also be that there is no finite
tree at
all or there is an Infinity where this
infinite party has cost zero this could
also happen if some edges are free if
you do not have to pay for them
then also need this infinite
trees but yeah otherwise you're right I
think okay so now we have these nice
trees and all there is left to do is to
prove how we can compute these and this
is obviously or this is a bit technical
but I don't want to go into details here
the idea is as follows if we zoom in on
this deterministic part we have the same
pattern repeated and I said that
iteration corresponds to trees so if we
do end steps of the iteration it covers
basically everything that happens in
trees of Fight n so it covers this
pattern that is repeated and if we just
apply this infinite power operation it
accounts for repeating this tree
infinitely often we still have this
prefix part this prefix again remember n
layers correspond to n steps of the
iteration so we just do n steps but we
start from the value of these child
trees here which is covered by this
expression so we obtain this expression
in total and this proves the main
result so this a bit technical but once
we have this nice trees this is
relatively easy to do so the key
ingredients really are that we have a
polinomial operator and that we have
absorption to simplify these
trees now I think I still have a few
minutes left so I uh briefly want to
talk about how we can apply this back to
data lock to Define circuit
representations because the title what
was algorithmic aspects that's a plural
so there need to be uh another
application here and what we have
already seen before or mentioned before
is that this Provence information it can
become large so we can efficiently
compute these greatest fixed points it
takes only a polinomial number of
operations but if each operation doubles
the size of the polinomial we still have
an exponentially large polinomial in the
end and this is not avoidable for
example here the transitive closure of
this graph has to be exponential because
there just are so many ways to uh to go
from U to W as you can see so we cannot
avoid this in general but what can be
done and what what has what has been
done in this 2014 page paper uh is to
Define circuit representations to encode
this polinomial more efficiently but you
could argue that in this case a nice
encoding would be the graph itself and
this will work as well but of course
this approach works in the general
case how does it work um where we
already have these equation systems so
we can just use them and turn them into
circuits so we have two layers this
addition node and then for each monomial
this multiplication node and then we
have a sing value or an indeter it we
can do this for every equation of the
system so we get a layer and this layer
can be
stacked how how often do we have to
stack this layer this is a question that
every one of you should now be able to
answer of course end times because the
least fixed point is reached after
iterating end types right each layer is
basically one iteration we start from
zero now of course you connect these
layers so that the IND determinat here
are connected to the corresponding roots
of the next layer um now we want to turn
this apply this approach to stratify
data loog and we can do this remember
the idea was that we dualize these
equation systems and we can just do the
same on the circuits so we take the
circuit for T and now dualize it to
obtain a circuit for the negation of T
except that here we need the greatest
fix point which is not necessarily
reached here in some semi Rings it is
like in for wol in other semi Rings it's
not so we have to adhere to this
expression and add another round of end
steps and this intermediary layer in
between
so assuming that it's fine to use this
operation and in fact this operation is
usually very easy to compute in semi
Rings uh then we also here have a
surface representation now which is
still of polinomial
size okay and that's oh there are some
questions
yeah yeah that's exactly what I want to
ask Infinity this is this is the this
infinite power operation so it's
basically the infome over so basically
you you take an element you multiply it
by itself and you get a downward chain
of this and it converges to some number
St no it does not uh converge in finite
number of steps in general so then how
would that guarantee the size of the
yeah so that's the point uh so um
you yeah I think there is no General way
to to have a circuit to compute this but
in all the semi rings that we are look
at this is actually easy to compute so
if you have a polinomial for example the
semi ring of generalized absorptive
polinomial that we have seen on the last
talk you just replace every exponent by
Infinity if you use a tropical sem you
just multiply by
Infinity so in all of the semies that I
have looked at it's very easy to compute
this but you have to be able to do this
in order to have this circuit
representation easy semi ring like can I
define an operator that only is
dependent only the semi not on the
actual data
right can function
that yes but it will be different for
different semi Rings
yes this was both of your questions
another question so let me do aity check
so we have the polom xals x is it true
that the least over the tropical s is it
true that the least fixed point is
infinity but the greatest point is
zero you mean you have an oper the
identity operator or we have a pol X X
over The Tropical is it that the point
is infinity but the greatest point is
zero uh yes I think
yeah okay so if there are no further
questions then let me let me conclude
the talk by brief summary so the main
result here is that we can compute
greatest fixed points in absorptive semi
Rings also assuming this continuity
assumption which is more more technical
by combining these trees and the the
absorption property um and then there's
also some connection to stify data loog
so we can define a semi semantics
fortify data lock by this idea of
negation normal form which we can
Implement here by dualizing these
equation systems and then Computing the
great Solutions and this can also be
turned into circuit
representations and now to end this talk
I have two open questions the first one
is actually slightly embarrassing
because we are still looking a bit for
applications of this this semantics so
to explain this our motivation is more a
theoretical one we wanted to look how
far can we push the semir framework to
which kind of Logics and for Le fix P
logic we have find this nice application
of strategy analysis in infinite games
but these games are not expressible in
straty data loog so here we would need
something else we can do a lot of things
like how provenance and repairs of
databases but these can all be done in
the the popol semi ring which is simpler
the question is is there also
application which needs for example the
tropical semi ring or more General
absorptive semi Rings the second
question is on alternating fixed points
also something which is not present in
stratify data lock but is a sorry which
is present in fix Point logic so the
first part is if we have a greatest fix
point that is defined by a least fix
Point inside can we still apply this
formula here because this one assumes
the operator to be polinomial but what
if there's the least fix Point inside
spoiler the answer is yes we can but
it's not I think it's not immediately
obvious why this is the case and then
what's the complexity of this if we have
an alternation death of of Ned operators
usually the approach is exponential in
this death but there have been thisi
polinomial breakthroughs for parity
games which are also applicable to
alternated fix Point evaluation and
these work for the Boolean semi ring and
also have finite height luses and so I
think absorptive semi Rings might be
just on the border of this result can be
generalized too because they can be
infinite we can have infinite iterations
as we have seen but still we have these
relatively easy ways to compute these
fixed points so this would be really
interesting but I don't have an answer
to this yet this really is an open
problem that's all thanks a lot for your
attention and I'm happy to take further
questions